de nouveaux arrivants après un pub et
restaurants mois de septembre c'est un
burger stakhovsky a pris ses quartiers à
skywest ce concept italien est arrivé au
début du mois d'octobre les cibles de
l'ouest c'est dans les centres dans les
grands centres commerciaux pour réunir
c'est un dîner autour de la famille
toujours près des cinémas de nouvelles
arrivées à l'image d'un renouveau pour
le centre commercial depuis 2015 et son
rachat par le groupe hammerson également
propriétaire ne laisse pas saint quentin
skywest glisse vers le loisir et la
culture
le furet du nord est la première
enseigne à s'installer en octobre 2017
l'orientation qu'on a souhaité donner à
skywest est défini selon la
complémentarité que nous avons voulu
avec espace 50 ans l'espace saint
quentin le centre historique qui est
plutôt une destination de shopping
donc on a souhaité compléter cette
destination de shopping avec une
destination loisirs et culture et la
phase 3 qui se verra à partir de début
2010 neuf et qui complétera le projet
avec l'arrivée des oueds aucune enseigne
de simulation de voitures de formule 1
sur vera une salle de sport sur 1300 m²
et une autre en scène de divertissement
avec laquelle nous sommes en échange
actuellement chaque année les centres
skywest et espace saint quentin
accueille environ 15 millions de
visiteurs avec ces nouvelles ouvertures
la direction vise les 20 millions